a senior I was a senior and then he will
be like I'm going to come up there and
then he came up one time and I start
punching myself in the face I could hit
myself harder than you can hit me that
is a big curve ball though your son's
just whooping on himself yeah so if
you're out there and your parents be in
your ass if you beat TR strategy would
you suggest that type of solution for
like other kids whose parents abuse them
in other ways I think so maybe because
it's less like cuz now you dark what if
your father like touches you though you
touch him you touch him more wait wait
what sorry is this bad what he's saying
is like what if your dad more then do
you more
yourself more more more
problem I said touch it like a kid way
too like touchy touchy oh my God it's so
dark catch that
algorithm don't challenge it